हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में
बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज
बता दीजिए।
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है। प्लीज
बता दीजिए एक बार चैट में। उसके बाद आपके
सवालों का मैं जवाब देता हूं। प्लीज
बताइए।
पहले आप लोग एक बार मेरा तो जवाब दे दे
दीजिए।
अच्छे से आ रही है। ओके वेरी गुड। तो पटेल
जी पूछ रहे हैं सर प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन और
क्लाउड के ऊपर कोई प्लेलिस्ट लाइए। तो
मेरे दोस्त क्लाउड तो इस सीरीज में
इनवॉल्व नहीं है बट आपका जो प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन है प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड
लेटरल मूवमेंट दोनों चीज मैं आपको इस
सीरीज में 100% सिखाने वाला हूं। तो इसलिए
थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिए। एक बार एक पोर्शन
कंप्लीट होने दीजिए। उसके बाद हमारे
नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल या नेक्स्ट पोर्शन पे हम
मूव ऑन करेंगे। तब तक के लिए थोड़ा सा आप
जो चीज मैं आपको सिखा रहा हूं आप उसको
सीखने की कोशिश कीजिए। समझ में आया पटेल
जी? हम सीखेंगे प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन पूरा
मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा। इस पे फ्री में
सिखाऊंगा। बट अभी के लिए आपको क्या करना
है? पहले जो हमारा एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मॉड्यूल
चल रहा है उसको कंप्लीट कीजिए। ओके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो सब लोग आ गए। यार मुझे नहीं है। पता
नहीं सच में बताऊं कि आप लोग मुझे इतना
डीमोटिवेट कर रहे हो अभी कि देखो मेरी
क्लास में एट टू नाइन स्टूडेंट ही आते
हैं। आई डोंट नो कि आप लोगों की आप लोगों
को क्या लगता है कि मैं आपको क्या या तो
मुझ में कमी है। मैं आप लोगों को कुछ गलत
पढ़ा रहा हूं। ओके? या फिर आपको लगता है
कि नहीं ये आपके काम की चीजें नहीं। आपको
सब कुछ आता है तो मुझे और कुछ पढ़ाना
चाहिए। दो रीजन हो सकते हैं। ठीक है? तो
आई डोंट नो कि आप लोग क्या चाहते हो
मुझसे। मैं अपनी तरफ से 100% आपको देने की
कोशिश करता हूं। हर चीज मैं आपको प्रोवाइड
कर रहा हूं। और मैं एक चीज की गारंटी देता
हूं। वीबीए के ऊपर जो मैं आपको सिखाने
वाला हूं ना पूरे YouTube पर कोई नहीं
होगा। सर्च कर लेना। फाइंड आउट कर लेना।
जो चीज मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकल सेशन में
डिलीवर करने वाला हूं। चाहे वो क्लास चार
क्लास हो, पांच क्लास हो या आठ क्लास हो।
टोटल उसका आउटपुट देखोगे ना अगर पूरे
YouTube स्ट्रीम पर आपको मिल जाए ना तो
मैं इसको डिलीट कर दूंगा YouTube से बताओ
आपको बेसिक मिल जाएगा सब कुछ बता देगा
लेकिन स्टेप बाय स्टेप जैसे मैं आपको समझा
रहा हूं आपको नहीं मिलने वाला बट आई डोंट
नो कि आप लोग
क्या समझते हो इस सीरीज को आई डोंट नो
क्योंकि मैं अपनी तरफ से 100% कोशिश करता
हूं आप लोग ना तो इसको लाइक करते हो ना
किसी के साथ शेयर करते हो इवन आप देखो
मेरी बेस्ट टू बेस्ट टेस्ट कितने लायक है?
25, 50, 80 इससे ज्यादा नहीं है। इवन आप
ही देखिए इतनी वैल्यू डाउन है क्या मेरी
क्लासेस की? यार शायद इतनी तो वैल्यू डाउन
होगी नहीं मेरी क्लासेस की जितना आप वो कर
रहे हो।
तो इस चीज के लिए अगर आप लोग ऐसा करोगे तो
सच में बता रहा हूं कि मैं सीरीज नहीं
कंटिन्यू करूंगा या मैं अपनी मर्जी से
आराम से सैटरडे संडे क्लास लूंगा और
छोटी-छोटी क्लासेस लूंगा। मुझे फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा यार। गुस्सा दिलाते हो आप लोग ऐसे
क्योंकि यार क्यों ना आए गुस्सा मेरे को?
तो क्यों ना मैं आप लोगों को ये चीज बोलूं
क्योंकि मैं आप लोगों के लिए सोच रहा हूं
कि डीएई जैसी सीरीज को कंटिन्यू करने की
मैं धीरे-धीरे उसकी फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ा रहा
हूं और आप लोग क्लासेस को ज्वाइन करना
छोड़ रहे हो।
पटेल जी मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि आप
ईजीपीटी बहुत ही आसानी से कर लोगे अगर
डीएचई आपने कंप्लीट कर लिया तो। मैं बोल
रहा हूं ये चीज। तो एक चीज मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। चलिए फिर जितने स्टूडेंट्स हैं
तो आप लोगों की एक प्रॉब्लम सॉल्व करने की
कोशिश की मैंने। आप लोगों ने बोला कि सर
हमें नोट्स नहीं मिल रहे। तो मैं एक काम
कर रहा हूं आप लोगों के लिए कि आप लोग अभी
जाइए। अभी के अभी चाहे अभी लाइव क्लासेस
वाले हो या आप रिकॉर्डिंग क्लासेस ही
क्यों नहीं क्यों ना देख रहा हो। आपको
क्या करना है? आपको अभी जाना है। आपको
डेफ्रोनिक्स पर जाना है। सॉरी YouTube के
ऊपर जाना है। YouTube के ऊपर डेफ्रोनिक्स
सर्च करना है।
डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी सर्च करना है। वहां पर
आपको आज की जो लाइव क्लास चल रही है उसी
के अंदर जाओ। मैं इसको उस क्लास के अंदर
जाइए और अभी मैं इसको पुट करता [संगीत]
हूं। ये ओके ऐड आ गई। और आपको क्या करना
है? अभी डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाना है।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाके आपको एक यहां पर
दिखाई देगा क्लासरूम नोट्स लिंक। ठीक है?
आपके लिए एक क्लास रूम नोट्स लिंक यहां पर
मैंने ओपन किया। आपको इस पे क्लिक करोगे।
क्लिक करने के बाद आपके सामने एक Twitter
का ग्रुप ओपन होगा। तो प्लीज जो अभी लाइव
में हैं वह अभी इस ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर
लीजिए और जो रिकॉर्डिंग रिकॉर्डेड सेशंस
देख रहे हैं जो बाद में क्लास को देखते
हैं जो रिकॉर्डिंग रिकॉर्डिंग देखते हैं
क्लास की जिसको भी नोट्स चाहिए क्लास से
इस डीएचई सीरीज के या डीएचई सीरीज की आने
वाली जितनी भी क्लासेस होंगे उनके भी
नोट्स चाहिए या प्रीवियस क्लासेस के जो
नोट्स चाहिए या जो करंट क्लास के जो नोट्स
चाहिए मैं जब आप लोग विदिन टू थ्री डेज
फाइव डेज या सिक्स डेज में आप लोग इस पे
ज्वॉइ कर लोगे। जॉइ जॉइ करने के बाद
आप ज्वॉइ करने के बाद आपको क्या करना है?
वेट करना है। मैं आपके साथ नोट शेयर
करूंगा। क्या बोल रहे हो भाई?
आपने क्या बोला अभी कि सर बोर क्यों कर
रहे हो?
सर बोर कर रहे हो आप। एक काम कीजिए मैं
बोर कर रहा हूं तो आप क्लास छोड़कर जा
सकते हो ओके
तो कितने लोगों ने अभी ग्रुप ज्वाइन किया
है मैं देखता हूं अभी के लिए जस्ट ओके गुड
बहुत सारे लोगों ने ज्वाइन करना स्टार्ट
कर दिया है बहुत अच्छी बात है आप लोगों को
इस पे नोट्स मिलना स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे बहुत
लोगों ने अभी ज्वाइन करना स्टार्ट कर दिया
है
गुड अच्छी बात है तो चलिए फिर हम सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी के अभी तो मैं सबसे
पहले आपको ले चलता हूं अपने प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन पर चलने वाले हैं। तो हम ओपन करते
हैं वर्ड। चलिए फिर वर्ड को ओपन करते हैं।
गो टू योर ब्लैंक डॉक्यूमेंट और ब्लैंक
डॉक्यूमेंट आपको क्या है? गो टू डेवलपर
टैब मैक्रोच। यहां पर आपको क्या करना है?
अह एक काम करेंगे। इसको करने से ये रहा।
यहां हम लिखेंगे टेस्ट।
टेस्ट केस टेस्ट केस हमने लिखा यहां पर और
यहां पर हम क्या करें? सेलेक्ट क्या करना
है हमें? डॉक्यूमेंट वन उसके बाद क्रिएट
करना है। डॉक्यूमेंट वन
और क्रिएट करना है।
चलिए आपके सामने एक स्क्रीन ओपन हो गई
होगी। सबको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है? सबको
यहां पर एक स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है? पॉप
अप आपको दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पर? ये रहा।
दिखाई दे रहा है स्क्रीन पर? प्लीज जल्दी
से मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए। प्लीज जल्दी
से चैट में बता दीजिए। सब कुछ दिखाई दे
रहा है? आपको स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है?
चलिए तो आगे बढ़ने से पहले एक चीज मैं आप
लोगों से से पूछना चाहता हूं। ठीक है? वह
क्या चीज है? कि प्रीवियस क्लास में मैंने
आपके सामने आपके साथ एक चीज डिस्कस की थी।
ओके? एक चीज डिस्कस की थी। वह क्या थी कि
यह चारों ऑप्शंस आपको क्लियर हो गए थे। ऑल
एक्टिव टेंपलेट्स एंड डॉक्यूमेंट्स,
ग्लोबल टेंपलेट, वर्ड कमांड्स और
डॉक्यूमेंट। प्लीज जल्दी से बता बता
दीजिए। चारों को यह ऑप्शंस क्लियर हो गए
थे।
यह ऑप्शन अगर चारों को क्लियर थे जिसमें
हमने प्रीवियस क्लास में यह कवर किया था।
तो अभी आप लोगों के लिए एक असाइनमेंट है।
प्लीज उसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए।
असाइनमेंट क्या है? आपके लिए रिसर्च
रिसर्च है। वो आपको फाइंड आउट करना है।
ठीक है? वो असाइनमेंट वो असाइनमेंट आपको
फाइंड आउट करना है। और देखते हैं कि कितने
लोग उसको फाइंड आउट कर पाते हैं। कितने
लोग उसको एक्चुअल में यूज कर पाएंगे।
बिल्कुल आपका
एक रियल वर्ल्ड से रिलेटेड असाइनमेंट है।
ओके? तो, यह आपका असाइनमेंट है आपके
स्क्रीन के ऊपर। असाइनमेंट में क्या है कि
आपका सिनेरियो क्वेश्चन क्या है? इफ
नॉर्मल डॉट एम डज़ नॉट ट्रेवल टू द रिमोट
टारगेट मशीन। हाउ डू रेटिमस ओवराइट कॉमन
कमांड्स लाइक फाइल सेव, फाइल प्रिंट इन द
विक्टिम्स लोकल नॉर्मल डॉट एम टेंप्लेट।
जैसा कि आप सबको पता है कि मैंने प्रीवियस
क्लास में क्या बताया था कि जो नॉर्मल डॉट
जो टेंपलेट होती है जो नॉर्मल ऑप्शंस होता
है आपका स्कोप इन के अंदर ओके माइक्रो इन
के अंदर जो सेकंड ऑप्शन होता है आपका
नॉर्मल डॉट का जिसको हम ग्लोबल टेंपलेट भी
बोलते हैं या जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड है
उसके जो मेन टेंपलेट भी है जब आप यह ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट करके आप अपना मिलिशियस कोड लिखते
हो और मिलेशियस कोड लिखने के बाद
डॉक्यूमेंट को पैक करके आप अपने विक्टिम
के पास पास भेजते हो। विक्टिम मतलब आप
अपने टारगेट के पास भेजते हो। तो क्या
होता है कि जो आपका मैक कोड था वह मै कोड
ट्रैवल नहीं करता। सबको पता है यह चीज
आपका जो मैक कोड है वो ट्रैवल नहीं करता।
रेदर देन आपका जो डॉक्यूमेंट है सिर्फ
डॉक्यूमेंट ट्रैवल करता है। उसके अंदर
मैकोड नहीं होता और एम्प्टी डॉक्यूमेंट
जाता है। ये चीज सबको पता होगी। तो अभी
मेरा सवाल यह है आप लोगों से। आपका
असाइनमेंट यह है जिस पर आपको रिसर्च करनी
है। बिल्कुल डीप रिसर्च करनी है। जब अगर
जो ग्लोबल टेंपलेट है ग्लोबल टेंपलेट का
जो मैक कोड है विक्टिम मशीन पे ट्रैवल
नहीं करता। लेकिन फिर भी जो रेटिमर्स होते
हैं जो आपका जो विक्टिम मशीन होती है
विक्टिम मतलब आपका जो टारगेट सिस्टम है
उसके अंदर जो ग्लोबल डॉट जो ग्लोबल
टेंपलेट होती है नॉर्मल डॉट एम है उसके जो
कॉमन कमांड्स होती है जैसे फाइल सेव हो
गया फाइल प्रिंट हो गया फाइल क्लोज हो गया
या जो मोस्ट कॉमन कमांड्स होती है ओके जो
मोस्ट कॉमन कमांड्स होती है फिर भी उसको
वह ओवराइड कैसे कर लेते हैं आपका टास्क
क्या है कि वो आपका टास्क यह है कि आपको
स्टेप बाय स्टेप वो मैकेनिज्म फाइंड आउट
करना है। वो अटैक वेक्टर आपको फाइंड आउट
करना है कि एक रेड टिमर टारगेट सिस्टम के
ऊपर जो ग्लोबल टेंपलेट है उसके जो कॉमन
कमांड्स हैं उसको कैसे ओवराइड कर सकता है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? आपका टास्क आपको समझ
में आ गया। आपको क्या करना है? आपको आपका
प्रोजेक्ट आपको आपका टास्क समझ में आ गया?
क्योंकि जब हम यह प्रैक्टिकल सेशन कंप्लीट
कर लेंगे तब आपको यह खुद से टास्क परफॉर्म
करके देखना है आपकी लोकल मशीन पर।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? आपको आपका असाइनमेंट
क्लियर है? प्लीज टेक ए स्क्रीनशॉट या
इसको कहीं पर नोट डाउन कर लीजिए। आपको
असाइनमेंट समझ में आया? प्लीज जल्दी से
बताइए।
आपको आपका असाइनमेंट समझ में आया? जल्दी
से चैट में बताइए।
आपको समझ में आया?
समझ में आया आपको?
और सब ने लिंक ज्वाइन कर लिया। ग्रुप का
लिंक जहां पर आपको नोट्स मिलने वाले हैं।
यह जो पीपीटी है सबने ज्वाइन कर लिया। अगर
नहीं ज्वाइन किया है तो प्लीज आज के जो
सेशन है सेशन के डिस्क्रिप्शन में वो लिंक
दिया गया है। आप उसको ज्वाइन कर सकते हो।
तो चलिए फिर अगर यह चीज आपको समझ में आ गई
तो बहुत अच्छी बात है। हम चलते हैं अपने
डॉक्यूमेंट के ऊपर। ठीक है? हम चलते हैं
अपने डॉक्यूमेंट के ऊपर जिसे हम करना है।
अभी मैं जस्ट आपके सामने क्या करने वाला
हूं? मैं आपके सामने एक कोड लिखने वाला
हूं। अभी आपको इस कोड को समझने की जरूरत
नहीं है। जस्ट अभी आप देखो। उसके बाद मैं
आपको समझाता हूं। क्योंकि यह कोड एक बार
मैं आपको लिखूंगा। लिखने के बाद
एग्जीक्यूट करके दिखाऊंगा। देन उसके बाद
मैं आपको हर एक चीज कोड के बारे में
धीरे-धीरे स्टेप बाय स्टेप क्लासेस बाय
क्लासेस मैं आपको समझाऊंगा। तो चलिए फिर
हम प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पर मूव ऑन करते हैं।
तो यह आपको दिखाई दे रहा हो स्क्रीन पर।
तो अभी हम क्या कर रहे हैं इसको?
चलो
यहां पर हम अभी कोड लिखते हैं। तो आई थिंक
यहां पर
साइज नहीं बढ़ सकता इसका। मे बी आई एम
ट्राइंग टू
नहीं इसका साइज नहीं बढ़ रहा। वेट
यहां पर इसका साइज नहीं बढ़ सकता।
किसी को पता है तो प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए।
बट मुझे नहीं पता इसका साइज कैसे
हॉरिजॉन्टल स्पेसिंग वर्टिकल स्पेस फॉर्म
बट मैं बीबी इसका साइज नहीं बढ़ सकता।
क्या फायदा यार डेली क्लासेस लेने का? आप
लोग
आते तो हो नहीं। मदर स्टूडेंट से क्या कर
लूंगा?
चलिए कोई कोई दिक्कत नहीं। अभी मैं आपको
एक कोड रन करके दिखाता हूं। उसके बाद यह
चलो हम सबसे पहले अपना कोड लिखते हैं।
डिम
एंप्लई सैलरी
एज डबल
डीम
बोनस एज
डबल
प्लीज आप लोग अभी देखते जाइए कि क्या होने
वाला है। उसके बाद मैं आपको सारी चीजें
समझा दूंगा। आपको चिंता करने की जरूरत
नहीं है।
यहां पर एक फंक्शन का नाम लिख रहा हूं
मैं।
टोटल बोनस
गुड एसेंट एंड
एएमपी बोनस
बोनस
ओके यह हो गया हमारा यहां पर मैं अभी
क्लोज कर देता हूं देन उसके बाद अब यह कोड
आपको नहीं समझ में आएगा क्योंकि मैंने अभी
तक कोड समझाया नहीं है बट मैं आपको कुछ
चीज परफॉर्म करके दिखाता हूं उसके बाद
समझाऊंगा आपको इस चीज को आपको परेशान होने
की जरूरत नहीं है
फंक्शन उसके बाद मैंने
इस
कैलकुलेट वेट वेट
बोनस एंप्लॉय
दिस वन
फंक्शन नेम दिस वाला देन उसके बाद हम
लिखते हैं यहां पर
सैलरी एज बोनस डबल
सैलरी एज डबल उसके बाद डाटा टाइप फिर से
डबल
देन उसके बाद हमने लिखा यह एंड फंक्शन
होगा उसके बाद
कैलकुलेट
बोनस
सैलरी
इंटू
10 मे बी हो गया। तो अभी हम क्या क्या
करते हैं? इसको रन करके दिखाता हूं आपको।
यहां पर अभी मैं रन करके देख लेता हूं।
टेस्ट केस और मैं इसको क्या करता हूं? अभी
रन करके देखता हूं। देखिए यहां पर कुछ आया
आपको सैलरी प्रोसेस होगी टोटल बोनस ज़ीरो।
सैलरी प्रोसेस होगी टोटल बोनस ज़ीरो। ओके?
तो कुछ आपको दिखाई दे रहा है पॉप अप?
कोड रन हुआ।
कोई एरर नहीं थी इसलिए आपके सामने कोड रन
हो गया।
सबको दिखाई दे रहा है? तो चलिए फिर एक काम
करते हैं। ओके किया हमने और ये तो अभी हम
आते हैं अपने कांसेप्ट के ऊपर। ठीक है?
अभी हम आते हैं अपने कांसेप्ट के ऊपर जो
मैं आपको सिखाने की कोशिश करूंगा। नाउ वी
आर डिस्कसिंग वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट फंडामेंटल
बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक्स ऑफ़ पीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग
दैट इज प्रोसीजर। मतलब क्या है कि यह अभी
जो विंडो आपको दिखाई दे रही है यहां पर जो
अभी यह मूव कर रही है जिसको मैं मूव करवा
रहा हूं इसको हम प्रोसीजर बोलते हैं। जो
भी कोड हम लिखते हैं वीबी के अंदर जो भी
मै कोड लिखते हैं जो भी आपने कमांड लिखी
जो भी इंस्ट्रक्शंस लिखी इसको हम क्या
बोलते हैं आपको प्रोसीजर बोलते हैं। इस
चीज को हम क्या बोलते हैं? प्रोसीजर बोलते
हैं। इस चीज को हम क्या बोलते हैं?
प्रोसीजर बोलते हैं। तो चलिए फिर हम समझते
हैं कि यह प्रोसीजर होता क्या है? ओके यह
प्रोसीजर होता क्या है? तो नाउ लेट्स
स्टार्ट विद ए प्रोसीजर। तो
चलिए मैं अभी पेन ऑन कर लेता हूं। यह रहा।
नाउ वीबीए कोड इज रिटन विद इन ए प्रोसीजर।
वीबीए कोड इज रिटन विद इन ए प्रोसीजर एंड
ए प्रोसीजर्स और सब प्रोसीजर्स इज ए सीरीज
ऑफ वीबीए स्टेटमेंट इंस्ट्रक्टिंग व्हाट
टू डू। मतलब क्या है? कि वीबीए में जब भी
आप कोई भी कोड लिखते हो जैसे आपने यह कोड
लिखा है या यह कोड लिखा है मतलब वीबीए के
अंदर आप जब भी कोई भी कोड लिखते हो वह
हमेशा एक प्रोसीजर्स के अंदर लिखा जाता
है। वो हमेशा एक प्रोसीजर के अंदर लिखा
जाता है। जो आपके सामने विंडो दिखाई दे
रही है जो अभी मैंने आपको दिखाई थी। इस
विंडो के अंदर हमने अपना कोड लिखा था। तो
यह पूरा पूरा कोड किसके अंदर लिखा गया है?
एक प्रोसीजर के अंदर। अब यह जो प्रोसीजर
है या जो सब प्रोसीजर्स है यह होता क्या
है? इसके बारे में जानते हैं। नाउ ए
प्रोसीजर्स और ए सब प्रोसीजर्स इज ए सीरीज
ऑफ वीबीए स्टेटमेंट्स इंस्ट्रक्टिंग व्हाट
टू डू। मतलब क्या है? जो प्रोसीजर्स या सब
प्रोसीजर्स एक ग्रुप ऑफ स्टेटमेंट होता
है। मतलब जो भी कोड है, जो भी कमांड है,
उनका एक ग्रुप होता है। जैसे कि आपको
स्क्रीन पे दिखाई दे रहा। यहां पे बहुत
सारी कमांड है, बहुत सारे कोड लिखे हुए
हैं। बहुत सारी इंस्ट्रक्शंस लिखी हुई
हैं। उनका एक ग्रुप क्या कहलाता है?
प्रोसीजर्स होता है। ओके? उनका एक ग्रुप
प्रोसीजर्स होता है। जो किसी भी एक
प्रोग्राम को इंस्ट्रक्शन देता है। किसी
भी एक प्रोग्राम को बताता है कि आपको क्या
करना है और कैसे करना है। जैसे हमने क्या
किया था? हमने अपना कोड लिखा। कोड लिखने
के बाद हमने क्या किया? उसको रन किया। रन
करने के बाद एक पॉपअप आया। पॉपअप में एक
इंफॉर्मेशन लिखी हुई थी। कैलकुलेशन थी,
वैल्यू थी। आपने उसको ओके कर दिया। तो, यह
क्या हुआ? यह आपका
यह क्या है? एक पूरी प्रोसेस हुई। आपने
अपने प्रोसीजर्स के अंदर इंस्ट्रक्शन
लिखी। आपने प्रोग्राम को यह बताया कि आपको
क्या काम करवाना है। अंडरस्टुड? आपको यह
चीज समझ में आ गई होगी। सैलरी की स्पे
स्पेलिंग गलती हो सकती है। डोंट वरी।
मैं आपको जस्ट बताने की कोशिश कर रहा था
कि मैं आपको क्या चीज परफॉर्म करके दिखाने
वाला हूं। देन उसके बाद बात करते हैं।
एक्चुअल में प्रोसीजर्स है क्या? तो
प्रोसीजर्स आर ए ग्रुप ऑफ स्टेटमेंट्स
एग्जीक्यूटेड एज ए वॉल वि इंस्ट्रक्ट हाउ
टू परफॉर्म ए स्पेसिफिक टास्क।
मतलब मतलब क्या है? कि जो प्रोसीजर
प्रोसीजर्स है यह एक ग्रुप ऑफ स्टेटमेंट
होता है। जिसको हम क्या बोलते हैं?
प्रोसीजर्स। प्रोसीजर्स को हम क्या बोलते
हैं? ग्रुप ऑफ स्टेटमेंट। वो सारे के सारे
क्या होते हैं? एक साथ एग्जीक्यूट करते
हैं। वह सारे के सारे एक साथ एग्जीक्यूट
होते हैं किसी स्पेसिफिक टास्क को कंप्लीट
करने के लिए। जैसे कि अभी आपने देखा था।
अब जो टास्क वो परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं, वह
टास्क बिल्कुल सिंपल भी हो सकता है या एक
कॉम्प्लिकेटेड टास्क भी हो सकता है या
कॉम्प्लेक्स टास्क भी हो सकता है। तो,
यहां तक मुझे यह चीज बताइए। सबको एक चीज
पता चल गई। प्रोसीजर्स क्या होता है?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? एक चीज सबको पता है
प्रोसीजर्स क्या होता है? प्लीज मुझे चैट
में जल्दी से बताइए। सबको यह चीज समझ में
आएगी। प्रोसीजर्स होता क्या है?
समझ में आया?
प्लीज चैट में जल्दी बताइए। प्रोसीजर्स
होता क्या है? सबको समझ आया?
प्रोसीजर्स क्या है? ग्रुप ऑफ स्टेटमेंट्स
जो एक साथ एग्जीक्यूट होते हैं किसी
स्पेसिफिक टास्क को परफॉर्म करने के लिए।
अब वो टास्क कॉम्प्लेक्स भी हो सकता है और
सिंपल भी हो सकता है। बस दैट्स ऑल। यह है
आपका प्रोसीजर्स। किसके अंदर? वीवीए के
अंदर। अब प्रोसीजर्स के अंदर आपके सारे
कोड एग्जीक्यूट होते हैं। सारा कोड लिखा
जाता है।
आप लोग यस या नो भी नहीं बोल सकते यार।
ओनली दो स्टूडेंट हैं जो यस या नो बता रहे
हैं। बाकी सब क्या कर रहे हो बताइए?
ओके। तो अभी हम बात करते हैं। अभी मैं
आपसे नहीं पूछने वाला। मैं जस्ट आपको
पढ़ाता चला जाऊंगा। तो देयर आर टाइप्स ऑफ
प्रोसीजर। प्रोसीजर्स के दो टाइप होते
हैं। सबसे पहला होता है फंक्शन। दूसरा
होता है सब प्रोसीजर्स। तो सबसे पहले हम
बात करते हैं फंक्शन होता क्या है? सबसे
पहले हम बात करते हैं फंक्शन होता क्या
है? ए फंक्शन इज ए ग्रुप ऑफ रयूजेबल कोड
व्हिच कैन बी कॉल्ड एनीवेयर इन योर
प्रोग्राम। व्हिच कैन बी कॉल्ड एनीवेयर इन
योर प्रोग्राम। और यह क्या है? ग्रुप ऑफ
रयूजेबल कोड। दिस एलिमिनेट्स द नीड ऑफ
राइटिंग द सेम कोड ओवर एंड ओवर अगेन। मतलब
क्या है? जो फंक्शन क्या है? फंक्शन एक
ग्रुप ऑफ रयूजेबल कोड है जिसे आप अपने
प्रोग्राम में कहीं से भी कॉल कर सकते हो।
और इसका सबसे बड़ा फायदा क्या होता है?
इसका सबसे बड़ा फायदा यह होता है कि आपको
सेम लॉजिक या कैलकुलेशन को बार-बार रिपीट
करके लिखने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ती। फायदा
क्या होता है? कि सेम लॉजिक है या सेम
कैलकुलेशन है किसी चीज की तो उसको आपको
बार-बार रिपीट नहीं करना पड़ता। बस आपको
क्या करना है? एक बार एक फंक्शन डिजाइन
करना है। उस कैलकुलेशन को एक बार उसका एक
लॉजिक लिखना है। उसके बाद आप अपने पूरे
प्रोग्राम में उस फंक्शन को मल्टीपल जगह
पर एक साथ एक ही टाइम पर आसानी से
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं, कॉल कर सकते हैं,
यूज कर सकते हैं। इसीलिए क्या है? फंक्शन
क्या है? एक ग्रुप ऑफ रयूजेबल कोड जिसे आप
अपने प्रोग्राम में कहीं पर भी यूज कर
सकते हैं। एंड दिस हेल्प द प्रोग्रामर टू
डिवाइड ए बिग प्रोग्राम इनू ए नंबर ऑफ
स्मॉल एंड मैनेजेबल फंक्शनंस।
मतलब कि यह क्या करता है कि जो एक बहुत
बड़ा किसी भी प्रोग्रामर को
किसी किसी भी एक प्रोग्रामर को किसी बड़े
कोड को एक बहुत बड़ा कोड है। ठीक है? ठीक
है? उसको छोटे-छोटे पार्ट में डिवाइड करने
में हेल्प करता है। यह क्या करता है? एक
प्रोग्रामर को किसी बड़े प्रोग्राम को
छोटे-छोटे स्मालस्मॉल पार्ट्स में डिवाइड
करके के आसानी से मैनेजेबल बनाने में उसकी
क्या करता है? हेल्प करता है फंक्शन। नाउ
अभी दो टाइप्स के फंक्शनंस होते हैं
नॉर्मली। एक तो इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस होते
हैं। दूसरे यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस होते
हैं। नाउ अपार्ट फ्रॉम इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस
वीबीए अलाउज़ टू राइट यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शनंस एज वेल। वीपीए के पास अपने खुद
के इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस भी होते हैं। लेकिन
एलन इनबिल्ट फंक्शनंस के अलावा वीबीए आपको
यूजर डिफाइन फंक्शनंस लिख लिखने की
परमिशंस भी देता है। मतलब यह है कि आप खुद
के फंक्शन भी डिफाइन कर सकते हो वीबीए के
अंदर। जैसे कि उसका सिंटेक्स क्या है?
वीबीए में कोई भी कस्टम फंक्शनंस हमेशा
फंक्शन कीवर्ड से स्टार्ट होता है। फंक्शन
कीवर्ड से स्टार्ट होता है और एंड फंक्शन
स्टेटमेंट या एंड फंक्शन कीवर्ड से एंड
होता है। मतलब अगर आपको क्या करना है? कोई
कस्टम या कोई यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस लिखना
है। जैसे कि अभी हमने एक फंक्शन लिखा था
कैलकुलेट सैलरी बोनस। वो फंक्शन क्या था?
एक यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शन था। कस्टम फंक्शन
था। अगर आपको कोई भी फंक्शन लिखना है
वीबीए के अंदर तो उसका एक सिंटेक्स होता
है। वो हमेशा एक फंक्शन कीवर्ड से स्टार्ट
होता है और एंड फंक्शन कीवर्ड पे एंड होता
है। उसके बीच में आप क्या कर सकते हो?
कोई भी लॉजिकल स्टेटमेंट लिख सकते हो अपने
फंक्शन की रिक्वायरमेंट के हिसाब से। अगर
आप फंक्शन से आपको जो भी काम करवाना है
उसके लिए आप कोई भी लॉजिकल स्टेटमेंट उसके
अंदर लिखोगे। तो वह है आपका फंक्शन। तो
आपको पता चल गया कि फंक्शनंस को कैसे लिखा
जाता है।
कैसे काम करता है पता चल गया फंक्शन का
सिंटेक्स सबको क्लियर है फंक्शन का
सिंटेक्स सबको क्लियर है तो अभी आते हैं
हम सब प्रोसीजर पर अब सब प्रोसीजर होता
क्या है नाउ सब प्रोसीजर वर्क सिमिलर टू
फंक्शन व्हाइल सब प्रोसीजर्स डू नॉट
रिटर्न ए वैल्यू एंड फंक्शनंस मे और मे
नॉट रिटर्न ए वैल्यू। चलो मैं आपको सिंपल
भाषा में समझा देता हूं। सब प्रोसीजर्स है
बिल्कुल फंक्शनंस की तरह ही काम करता है।
लेकिन इनके बीच में जो फंक्शन और जो सब
प्रोसेस है उनके बीच में एक मेजर डिफरेंस
है। और वो डिफरेंस क्या है? फंक्शनंस
हमेशा एग्जीक्यूशन के बाद
अपने रिजल्ट में या तो कोई वैल्यू रिटर्न
करता है या कोई वैल्यू रिटर्न नहीं भी कर
सकता। मतलब दोनों ही केस हो सकते हैं। जब
जब एक फंक्शन एग्जीक्यूट होता है तो उसका
जो आउटपुट मिलता है उसके आउटपुट में कोई
वैल्यू रिटर्न भी हो सकती है और कोई
वैल्यू रिटर्न नहीं भी हो सकती। दोनों ही
केस हो सकते हैं। लेकिन सब प्रोसीजर्स के
केस में क्या होता है? सब प्रोसीजर्स के
केस में हमेशा कभी भी कोई वैल्यू रिटर्न
नहीं होती। मतलब यह है कि जो सब
प्रोसीजर्स है, वह कभी भी कोई भी वैल्यू
रिटर्न नहीं करता। वह बस अपना टास्क
परफॉर्म करता है। फंक्शन की तरह नहीं है
कि वह वैल्यू रिटर्न भी करे नहीं भी करे।
लेकिन यह वो फंक्शन के केस में होता है।
लेकिन जो सब प्रोसीजर्स होता है सब
प्रोसीजर कभी भी कोई वैल्यू रिटर्न नहीं
करता। याद रखिए वो सिर्फ अपना टास्क
परफॉर्म करता है। ठीक है? और दूसरी बात
फंक्शनंस को कॉल करने के लिए आपको कॉल
कीवर्ड का यूज करना पड़ सकता है। पड़ता भी
है कई जगह पर जो पुराने वर्जनंस है। लेकिन
सब प्रोसीजर के केस में ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं
है। सब प्रोसीजर्स को कॉल करने के लिए
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए कहीं पर भी आपको
कॉल कीवर्ड का यूज़ करना नहीं पड़ता। अगर
सिंटेक्स की बात करें तो सिंटेक्स है सबसे
पहले आप क्या यूज़ करते हो? सब कीवर्ड का
यूज़ करोगे। उसके बाद सब प्रोसीजर का नाम
उसके बाद एंड सब मतलब इसका जो सिंटेक्स है
इसका सिंटेक्स है कि सब कीवर्ड से स्टार्ट
होगा एंड सब कीवर्ड पे एंड होगा और इसके
बीच में आप अपना कोड लिखते हो अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन तो ये सबको समझ में आ गया फंक्शनंस
क्या होता है और सब प्रोसीजर्स क्या होता
है और कैसे लिखा जाता है क्योंकि जभी अभी
मैंने जो आपको कोड लिख के दिखाया था उस
कोड में यही चीजें थी एक तो यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शनंस मैंने आपको रन करके दिखाया था
दूसरा आपके सामने सब प्रोसीजर्स डिजाइन
किया था और किसके अंदर? प्रोसीजर के अंदर।
सब प्रोसीजर्स को हम सब रूटीन भी बोलते
हैं।
समझ में आ गया? तो आई होप कि जो कोड मैंने
अभी आपके सामने लिखा था वो कोड अभी आपको
थोड़ा-थोड़ा समझ में आ गया होगा कि सर ने
क्या लिखा था? उसके अंदर क्या-क्या
एग्जैक्ट मतलब है? डम क्या था? यह मैसेज
बॉक्स क्या था? यह चीज हम अभी डिस्कस
करेंगे। अभी हम पढ़ेंगे लेकिन अभी के लिए
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अभी के लिए आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा।
आ गया समझ में?
तो वेरी गुड। तो अभी एक काम करते हैं।
कमेंट कैसे लिख सकते हैं? मैं आपको बताता
हूं। सो प्रैक्टिकली चलते हैं हम कमेंट के
ऊपर। यह रहा। तो अभी अगर आपको क्या करना
हो? कोई भी कमेंट लिखने हैं अपने कोड के
अंदर प्रोग्राम के अंदर तो आप कमेंट दो
तरीके से लिख सकते हो। आप कमेंट दो तरीके
से लिख सकते हो। सबसे पहला तरीका कौन सा
है? तो चलिए मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। तो
यहां पर मैंने क्या किया? आपने देखा भी
था। आपको
सेम आपको कॉलन का यूज़ करना है। ठीक है? तो
सिंगल कोट का यूज़ करना है। सिंगल कोट।
उसके बाद हम लिखते हैं दिस स्क्रिप्ट। एक
मिनट।
ओके हां गुड दिस स्क्रिप्ट
इज
रिटन बाय नहीं दिस स्क्रिप्ट इज रिटन बाय
सचिन सर ओके देन उसके बाद सेकंड लाइन में
अगली कमेंट आप लिख सकते हो
ओके इट इज
बेस्ड ऑन सैलरी कैलकुलेशन
सैलरी
बोनस कैलकुलेशन
सैलरी बोनस कैलकुलेशन एक तो यह तरीका है
कमेंट लिखने का दूसरा कमेंट लिखने का
तरीका कौन सा है आर इएम रम कीवर्ड का यूज
करोगे उसमें भी आप लिख सकते हो
दिस इज
अनदर वे ऑफ अनदर वे टू रिटर्न
कमेंट।
ओके? यह देखो। अभी एक और चीज है। कमेंट
क्या होती है? यह वो कोड होता है या वो
पोर्शन होता है कोड के अंदर जो कभी भी
प्रोग्राम में एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होता। यह
सिर्फ यूज़र्स के लिए होता है। ताकि उसको
आसानी से समझ में आ जाए। वह अपने रेफरेंस
के लिए लिखता है कि मैं यह प्रोग्राम यह
पर्टिकुलर लाइन क्यों लिख रहा हूं। इसका
पर्पज क्या है कि वो आपके लिए होता है जो
कोड में कभी भी एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होता। तो
दो तरीके से आप कमेंट लिख सकते हो। एक तो
सिंगल कोड उसके बाद लिख सकते हो। दूसरा आर
इ एम कीवर्ड का यूज़ करके उसके बाद आप अपने
आप कमेंट लिख सकते हो। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
ये चीज समझ में आ गई आपको?
यह चीज समझ में आ गई?
इस तरीके से आप कमेंट लिख सकते हो।
नेक्स्ट आता है आते हैं हम मैसेज बॉक्स के
ऊपर। अभी मैंने आपके सामने क्या किया था?
यह एक मैसेज बॉक्स है और जैसे मैंने इसको
रन किया था। यह एक इसका पॉपअप आ गया। यह
जो आपके सामने पॉपअप आया जो बॉक्स दिखाई
दिया, यह किसके कारण आया? एक फंक्शन होता
है मैसेज बॉक्स। इसके कारण यह पॉपअप आया।
मैसेज बॉक्स एक फंक्शन होता है किसके
अंदर? वीबीए के अंदर। इसके कारण आपको यह
पॉपअप देखने को मिला। तो चलिए फिर इसको
समझते हैं कि यह चीज होती क्या है? यह किस
ब्ल का नाम है? तो चलो फिर इस ब्ल के बारे
में ही समझ लेते हैं कि किस ब्ल का नाम
है। तो चलो फिर नाउ
कमेंट के बारे में हम पढ़ चुके हैं। नाउ
कम्स टू योर मैसेज बॉक्स। द मैसेज बॉक्स
फंक्शन डिस्प्ले ए मैसेज बॉक्स एंड वेट
फॉर द यूजर टू क्लिक ए बटन एंड देन एन
एक्शन इज परफॉर्म बेस्ड ऑन द बटन क्लिक
बाय द यूजर। शायद इस लाइन से आपको कुछ भी
समझ में नहीं आया होगा। कोई दिक्कत नहीं।
मैं आपको समझा देता हूं। जो मैसेज बॉक्स
होता है, मैसेज बॉक्स वीबीए के अंदर एक
बिल्ट इन फंक्शन होता है। वीबीए के अंदर
एक इनबिल्ट फंक्शन है जो क्या करता है?
स्क्रीन पर एक डायलॉग बॉक्स पॉप अप करता
है। जो स्क्रीन पर क्या करता है? एक
डायलॉग बॉक्स डिस्प्ले करता है। और यह
डायलॉग बॉक्स क्या करता है? यूजर के सामने
एक मैसेज शो करता है। जैसे यहां पर दिखा
सैलरी प्रोसेस हो गई है। टोटल बोनस 5000
लाइक दैट। तो यह क्या करता है कि
डायलॉग बॉक्स यूजर के सामने एक मैसेज शो
करता है और वेट करता है। किसका वेट करता
है? यूजर का। यूजर का वेट करता है कि वह
किसी बटन पर क्लिक करे। जैसे कि ओके बटन
है, यस बटन है, नो बटन है, कैंसिल बटन है,
अबोर्ट बटन है, इंपोर्ट बटन है। मतलब वो
यूजर का वेट करता है। एक एक पॉपअप आया
पॉपअप में कुछ मैसेज शो किया। उसके बाद
यूजर के रिस्पांस का वेट करता है। उस पर
क्लिक करने का और जैसे ही यूजर उस बटन पर
क्लिक करता है, उसके हिसाब से प्रोग्राम
में अगला एक्शन परफॉर्म किया जाता है।
उसके हिसाब से प्रोग्राम में अगला एक्शन
परफॉर्म किया जाता है। अब इसका पर्पस जो
इसका यूज़ है किस पर्पस से किया जाता है?
इसका यूज़ हम यूजर को कोई नोटिफिकेशन शो
करने के लिए, कोई वार्निंग देने के लिए,
यूजर से कंफर्मेशन लेने के लिए या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में यूजर को एक प्रीटेक्स्ट
शो करने के लिए कि ओके जैसे यूजर ने इसको
ओपन किया यह आ गया कि आपका सॉफ्टवेयर
आउटडेटेड है। प्लीज क्लिक है और सॉफ्टवेयर
को अपडेट कीजिए। इस टाइप से आपने क्या कर
दिया? उसके सामने उसको यूज़ कर लिया। आप इस
तरीके से वह पॉपअप शो करवा सकते हो। ठीक
है? आप उस तरीके से वह पॉपअप शो करवा सकते
हो। तो आई होप कि मैसेज बॉक्स आपको समझ
में आ गया। अब इसका सिंटेक्स क्या होता
है? मैसेज बॉक्स का यह मैसेज बॉक्स का
सिंटेक्स है। मैसेज बॉक्स प्र्ट उसके बाद
बटन, टाइटल, हेल्प फाइल और कॉन्टेक्स्ट।
अगर आप इसमें ध्यान से देखोगे तो प्र्प के
अलावा जो बाकी यह आपको दिखाई दे रहा है
बटन टाइटल हेल्प फाइल और कॉन्टेक्स्ट सब
कुछ आपको स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट के अंदर दिखाई
दे रहा है। मतलब क्या है कि जो ये
स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट में आपको दिखाई दे रहा
है ना ये क्या है? सारा का सारा ऑप्शनल
है। ये सारा का सारा आपका क्या है?
ऑप्शनल।
यह सारा का सारा आपका ऑप्शनल है। इसमें
रिक्वायर्ड पैरामीटर क्या है? एक ही है।
यह आपका ऑप्शनल पैरामीटर है और यह आपका
रिक्वायर्ड है। यह आपका रिक्वायर्ड
पैरामीटर है। तो चलिए सबसे पहले इन सारे
पैरामीटर का मतलब समझते हैं कि हर एक
पैरामीटर का क्या मतलब है? भाई क्या हो
गया क्लास यार? मैं अकेला
क्लास को छोड़-छोड़ के क्यों चले जा रहे
हैं बंदे?
तो प्र्प की बात करते हैं। प्र्प क्या है?
एक रिक्वायर्ड पैरामीटर है। तो प्र्प के
बारे में समझते हैं। ए स्ट्रिंग दैट इज
डिस्प्लेड एज ए मैसेज इन द डायलॉग बॉक्स
एंड द मैक्सिमम लेंथ ऑफ प्र्प्ट इज
अप्रोक्समेटली 1024 कररेक्टर्स।
प्र्ट का मतलब क्या है? कि यह वो टेक्स्ट
मैसेज होता है जो डायलॉग बॉक्स के अंदर
हमें दिखाई देता है। जैसे अभी हमने देखा
था ना सैलरी प्रोसेस होगी। यह आपका टोटल
बोनस है। यह क्या होता है? आपका एक
प्र्प्ट होता है। जिसकी मैक्सिमम लेंथ
1024 कररेक्टर्स हो सकती है। नाउ इफ द
मैसेज एक्सटेंड टू मोर देन ए लाइन देन द
लाइन कैन बी सेपरेटेड यूजिंग ए कैरज
रिटर्न कैरेक्टर और ए लाइन फीड करैक्टर
बिटवीन ईच लाइन। इसका मतलब क्या है? अगर
आप मैसेज को दो अलग-अलग लाइंस में लिखना
चाहते हो तो आप लाइन के बीच में कैरज
रिटर्न और लाइन फीड जैसे कैरेक्टर्स का
यूज कर सकते हो। मतलब अगर आप लाइन को क्या
करना चाह रहे हो? सेपरेट करके लिखना चाह
रहे हो। अलग-अलग लाइन में लिखना चाह रहे
हो तब आप क्या कर सकते हो? इन दो कैरेक्टर
का यूज़ कर सकते हो या तो कैरज रिटर्न का
यूज़ कर सकते हो या फिर आप लाइन फीड का यूज़
कर सकते हो। सच बताऊं गाइस आज मैंने आप
लोगों के लिए सेशन प्लान किया और मैं इतने
अच्छे से सोच के आया था ना कि बेस्ट
पढ़ाऊंगा मतलब कि स्टूडेंट आएंगे आराम से
20 25 30 50 और मस्त अच्छा आराम से पूरा
सेशन बहुत अच्छे से तैयार करके आया था और
जैसे स्टार्टिंग में आपके स्टूडेंट देखी
टोटली डीमोटिवेट और जो प्रिपरेशन मैं आपके
लिए करके आया था वह मैं बस ऐसे कर ऐसे मन
किया कि अभी मैं बस आपको बस डिलीवर कर दूं
आप सुनते जाओ मैं डिलीवर करता जाऊं बस
टोटली डीमोटिवेट।
तो अभी चलते हैं हम नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन पर।
नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन आपका बटन।
नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन है आपका बटन। ओके? तो बटन
का मतलब क्या है? यह आपका एक ऑप्शनल
पैरामीटर है। बटन आपका एक ऑप्शनल पैरामीटर
है। और इस पैरामीटर में हम क्या करते हैं?
कांस्टेंट वैल्यू देते हैं। इस पैरामीटर
में हम एक कांस्टेंट वैल्यू देते हैं। ठीक
है? जो यह डिसाइड करता है क्या डिसाइड
करता है कि कौन सा बटन शो होगा कि कौन सा
बटन आपको स्क्रीन पे दिखाई देगा या कौन सा
बटन वो डायलॉग बॉक्स के अंदर दिखेगा ओके
यस या नो जैसे कि अभी-अभी देखा था कौन सा
आइकॉन दिखेगा कौन सा आइकॉन दिखेगा कोई
क्रिटिकल आइकॉन दिखेगा इंफॉर्मेशनेशन का
आइकॉन दिखेगा कोई क्वेश्चन मार्क का आइकॉन
दिखेगा या एस्केलेशन मार्क का आइकॉन
दिखेगा उस टेक्स्ट के अंदर कौन सा आइकॉन
दिखेगा दूसरा कौन सा बटन डिफॉल्ट हाईलाइट
रहेगा। कौन सा बटन? डिफॉल्ट हाईलाइट
रहेगा। आपने देखा है यस या नो रहता है। यस
या नो। और हमेशा एक पे थोड़ी सी हल्की सी
एक लाइन रहेगी। लाइट ब्लू लाइट लाइट ग्रे।
तो वो क्या होता है? डिफॉल्ट सेलेक्ट बटन
होता है कि अगर आप डिफॉल्ट पे एंटर करोगे
तो वो जिस पे वो सिलेक्टेड है उसी पे
जाएगा। रेदर देन आप उसको खुद से सेलेक्ट
नहीं करते। यस या नो। तो वो सारी चीज या
बॉक्स की मॉडिलिटी क्या है? बॉक्स की
मॉडलिटी क्या है? तो यहां पर आप क्या कर
सकते हो कि यहां पर आप एक कास्टेंट वैल्यू
देते हो। मैं आपको बताऊंगा वह वैल्यू
कौन-कौन सी होती है। सारी चीजें मैंने
आपके लिए यहां पर रखी हुई है। तो यहां पर
आप एक कांस्टेंट वैल्यू देते हो जो ये
डिसाइड करता है कि बॉक्स में कौन सा बटन
दिखाई देगा? कौन सा आइकॉन शो होगा। बटन का
डिफ़ॉल्ट डिफ़ॉल्ट हाईलाइटेड कौन सा बटन
रहेगा या बॉक्स की मॉडिलिटी क्या होगी?
अगर आप क्या कर देते हो? यहां पर कोई भी
वैल्यू नहीं देते। या इसको ब्लैंक छोड़
देते हो तो बाय डिफॉल्ट यहां पर जो
पैरामीटर रहता है वो वो रहता है यहां पर
वी बी
ओके ओनली वी बी ओके ओनली इस तरीके का एक
कांस्टेंट वैल्यू बाय डिफॉल्ट रहती है
जिसकी रिटर्न वैल्यू क्या है ज़ीरो जिसकी
रिटर्न वैल्यू ज़ीरो होती है। जैसे कि अभी
आपने जो देखा था वह आपका जो ओके बटन आ रहा
था वह बाय डिफॉल्ट रहता है। तो आई होप कि
आपको बटन पैरामीटर भी समझ में आ गया होगा।
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम टाइटल के ऊपर। अब यह
टाइटल भी एक ऑप्शनल पैरामीटर है। टाइटल भी
आपके सामने एक ऑप्शनल पैरामीटर है। टाइटल
भी आपका एक ऑप्शनल पैरामीटर है।
तो टाइटल में क्या होता है? ये दिखाई दे
रहा है आपको? यह आपका एक टाइटल बार होता
है। यह आपका टाइटल बार है। इसके अंदर आपको
अगर कोई भी स्ट्रिंग शो करवानी है। अगर
आपको इसके अंदर फॉर एग्जांपल इसका अभी तो
बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट क्या आ रहा है? Microsoft
Word आ रहा है। क्योंकि यहां पर इंटेंशनली
लेफ्ट ब्लैंक है। हां, यहां पर हमने क्या
कर दिया? टाइटल को लेफ्ट छोड़ दिया। खाली
छोड़ दिया। छोड़ दिया। यहां पर ब्लैंक
छोड़ दिया। उसकी वजह से क्या हो रहा है कि
एप्लीकेशन का नाम आ रहा है बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट।
लेकिन अगर आप यहां पर Microsoft Word की
जगह टाइटल बार में कुछ और वैल्यू कोई और
स्ट्रिंग देना चाहते हो तो आप यहां पर
टाइटल में दे सकते हो। आप क्या कर सकते
हो? वो स्ट्रिंग टेक्स्ट यहां पर टाइटल
में दे सकते हो। जिससे क्या होगा? जैसे ही
कोड एग्जीक्यूट होगा तो टाइटल बार में जो
डायलॉग बॉक्स है जो टाइटल बार है जो आपको
दिखाई दे रहा है यहां पर आपका जो स्ट्रिंग
है वो शो होगा। आपका स्ट्रिंग यहां पर शो
होगा। इसके बाद दो और ऑप्शंस हैं।
हेल्पफुल और कॉन्टेक्स्ट। ये हमारे किसी
काम के नहीं है। अभी हमें इसको पढ़ने की
जरूरत नहीं है। जस्ट इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन आप
खुद से देख लेना। अभी हम इसको नहीं पढ़ने
वाले और हमें इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट भी नहीं
है। तो आई होप आपको बटन आपको मैसेज बॉक्स
का जो सिंटेक्स था पूरा क्लियर हो गया
होगा कि प्र्प्ट का क्या काम है? बटन का
क्या काम है? टाइटल का क्या काम है। ठीक
है? आपको समझा देता हूं। देखो यह आपका
टाइटल है। यह आपका प्र्प्ट है। और यह आपका
यह आपका क्या है? बटन है। ठीक है? यह आपका
बटन प्र्ट, टाइटल और बटन। ठीक है? और यहां
पर अगर कोई एस्केलेशन मार्क होता, कोई
यहां पर आपका क्वेश्चन मार्क होता, कोई
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन सिंबल होता ना इस टाइप के
तो वो भी आपका क्या है? बटन के कारण ही
आता है। तो आई होप सबको समझ में आ गया
होगा। तो अभी हम बात करते हैं इस बटन के
जो बटन पैरामीटर्स है इसके बारे में थोड़ी
सी बात करते हैं कि बटन पैरामीटर्स में आप
कौन-कौन सी वैल्यू दे सकते हो। जो बटन
पैरामीटर्स है इसको लॉजिकली चार ग्रुप में
बांटा गया है। ये जो बटन पैरामीटर है इसको
लॉजिकली चार ग्रुप में बांटा गया है।
ग्रुप वन है आपका बटन ऑप्शन। इसमें आप जो
ग्रीन में वैल्यू दिखाई दे रहे हो आप यह
आप यहां पर लिख सकते हो खुद से। मैंने
बोला था ना हम एक कांस्टेंट वैल्यू देते
हैं। वी बी ओके ओनली वीबी ओके कैंसिल वीबी
अबाउट रिट्राई इग्नोर वीबी यस नो कैंसिल
वीबी यस नो वी बी रिटाई कैंसिल ये हम यहां
पर लिखते हैं और उसके बाद यहां पर जो
वैल्यू दिखाई ना 0 1 2 3 4 5 ये इसकी
रिटर्न वैल्यू है। अगर आप ये वैल्यू यहां
पर लिखते हो तो इसकी जो रिटर्न वैल्यू है
एग्जीक्यूट होने के बाद ये आती है वीबी
ओके ओनली की ज़ीरो रहती है। जैसे मैंने
आपको बताया था और ये इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन
है। अगर वीबी ओके ओनली आप देते हो तो इसका
मतलब आपको सिर्फ एक ओके बटन दिखाई देगा।
अगर वीबी ओके कैंसिल लिखते हो तो आपको ओके
और कैंसिल दो बटन दिखाई देंगे। अगर आप
वीबी अबाउट रिटाई इग्नोर लिखते हो तो आपको
अबाउट रिटाई इग्नोर तीन बटन दिखाई देंगे।
या फिर यह लिखते हो तो यस नो कैंसिल तीन
बटन दिखाई देंगे। यस या नो बटन के लिए यह
यूज़ करते हो। रिटाई और कैंसिल बटन के लिए
आप यह वाला ऑप्शन यूज़ करते हो। नेक्स्ट
अगर हम बात करें ग्रुप टू। ग्रुप टू में
क्या है? ग्रुप टोल आपका आइकॉन के लिए है।
अगर आपको क्रिटिकल मैसेज आइकॉन देखना है
तो आप इसका यूज कर सकते हो। वीबी क्वेश्चन
के लिए क्वेश्चन मार्क के लिए यह वाला यूज
कर सकते हो। एस्केलेशन मार्क के लिए ये
इनेशन मार्क्स के लिए आप यह वैल्यू यूज कर
सकते हो।
नेक्स्ट अगर हम बात करें ये रहा। यहां पर
आप दिखाई दे रहा है। मैंने आपको जैसा
बताया था। एक दो ऑप्शन है यस या नो मतलब
वीबी यस नो। उसके बाद आपको मैंने क्या
बताया था? यह थोड़ा सा लाइट ब्लू है। मतलब
यह हाईलाइटेड है। बाय डिफॉल्ट है। तो, यह
किसकी वजह से? इनवैल्यू की वजह से। कि
फर्स्ट बटन अगर डिफॉल्ट रहेगा, तो यहां आप
लिखते हो वीबी डिफॉल्ट बटन वन। अगर दो ही
बटन है, तो यहां पर लिखोगे वीबी डिफॉल्ट
बटन वन या बटन टू। ठीक है? अगर यहां पर
चार बटन होते हैं, तो आप लिखोगे कौन सा
बटन डिफ़ॉल्ट रहेगा? वीबी डिफ़ॉल्ट बटन
थ्री, वीबी डिफ़ॉल्ट फोर, वीबी डिफ़ॉल्ट बटन
टू, वीबी डिफ़ॉल्ट बटन वन। तो यह सारी
चीजें आप यहां पर मेंशन कर सकते हैं। कौन
सा बटन आपका डिफॉल्ट रहेगा? नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट आपका क्या है? ये रहा मॉडिलिटी।
अब मॉडिलिटी क्या होता है? मॉडिलिटी में
आपकी दो वैल्यू होती है। 0 और 4096 वीबी
एप्लीकेशन मॉडल और वीबी सिस्टम मॉडल।
एप्लीकेशन मॉडल में क्या होता है कि अगर
आपने यह सेलेक्ट किया तो एप्लीकेशन मॉडल
में क्या? जब यूजर क्या करेगा? मैसेज
बॉक्स को जब तक क्लोज नहीं करता तब तक जो
करंट एप्लीकेशन चल रही है आपकी जो एक्सेल
या वर्ड है उस पर आप कुछ भी काम नहीं कर
सकते। अगर आपने सेलेक्ट किया जो ये
डिफॉल्ट मोड होता है आपका अभी जो आपने
देखा था डिफॉल्ट मोड था वीबी एप्लीकेशन
मॉडल अगर वीबी सिस्टम मॉडल आपने सेलेक्ट
किया है वो दिया है तो इसका मतलब क्या है
कि जब तक आप उस प्र्ट पर यूजर रिस्पांस
नहीं करेगा सिस्टम में कोई भी एप्लीकेशन
काम नहीं करेगी ठीक है सिस्टम में कोई भी
एप्लीकेशन काम नहीं करने वाली ठीक है
सिस्टम में कोई भी एप्लीकेशन काम नहीं
करने वाली तो इसलिए यह थे आपके बटंस के
ऑप्शंस जो आप यूज़ कर सकते हो। नेक्स्ट
रिटर्न वैल्यू आपको क्या-क्या देखने को
मिलती है? वीबी ओके, वीबी कैंसिल, वीबी
अबाउट, वीबी रिट्रा, वीबी इग्नोर, वीबी
यस, वीबी नो। ये आपकी रिटर्न वैल्यू ही
आपको देखने को मिलती है। तो चलो इसको हम
एक प्रैक्टिकल कर दें। आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा। नेक्स्ट। चलो फिर। तो अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं? इसको बिल्कुल कंप्लीट क्लियर कर
देता हूं। जो आपको समझ में आ जाए। इसको
मैं अभी डिलीट कर देता हूं। नेक्स्ट।
ठीक है? और इसमें भी मैं इसको क्या कर
देता हूं अभी? डिलीट कर देता हूं। पूरी
तरह से मैंने डिलीट कर दिया। कुछ चीजें
हैं। हो सकता आपके लिए इसमें नहीं होंगी।
तो आपको सिर्फ समझना है मैसेज बॉक्स की
फंक्शनैलिटी। उसके लिए अब आपको बाकी चीजों
पे ध्यान नहीं देना है। बाकी चीजों पर
आपको ध्यान नहीं देना। तो चलिए फिर
प्रैक्टिकल करते हैं इसका। तो गिव मी वन
सेकंड गाइस नाउ।
तो हम लिखते हैं वेरिएबल। हमने वेरिएबल
लिखा
यूजर चॉइस
एज इंटजर
एज इंटीजर नेक्स्ट हम करते हैं अभी
यूजर चॉइस
यूजर चॉइस उसके अंदर वैल्यू हम सेट करते
हैं
मैसेज बॉक्स
देन
मैसेज बॉक्स में हम लिखते
डू यू
वांट टू
डिलीट
दिस फाइल। डू यू वांट टू डिलीट दिस फाइल?
उसके बाद यह फर्स्ट लाइन हमने लिख लिया।
देन उसके बाद हम यूज़ करेंगे एंड पैराटर्स
का। एंड पैरामीटर क्या है? कंकटिनेशन वाला
काम करते हैं। ओके? प्लस कंकटिनेशन और एंड
पैरामीटर भी इनहीं में काम करते हैं। उसके
बाद मैंने क्या बोला था? हम यूज कर सकते
हैं कैरज रिटर्न। हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं कैरज
रिटर्न। चलिए फिर हम कैरज रिटर्न कर लेते
हैं। जीरो कैरज रिटर्न उसके बाद एंड
पैरामीटर। देन उसके बाद हम क्या लिखेंगे?
फिर से हम लिखते हैं दिस एक्शन
कैन नॉट
कैन नॉट बी
अनडन।
चलिए अभी हमने ऐसे लिख लिया। उसके बाद
कॉमा किया हमने
देन उसके बाद कॉमा के बाद हम क्या करते
हैं अब लिखेंगे वीबी
यस या नो वीबी यस या नो उसके बाद प्लस
कंकटिनेशन
उसके बाद वीबी क्वेश्चन जैसे आप देख रहे
थे वीबी क्वेश्चन आपने लिखा देन अरे वेट
वेट वेट
ओके वीबी क्वेश्चन देन
प्लस आइकॉन देन हम लिखेंगे वीबी डिफॉल्ट
वीबी डिफॉल्ट बटन टू वीबी वीबी डिफॉल्ट
बटन टू वेट यार
डिफॉल्ट स्पेलिंग का देखना एक बार बेबी
डिफॉल्ट बटन
बटन टू देन उसके बाद हम क्या कर रहे हैं?
लिख रहे हैं
कंफर्म
डिलीशन।
नेक्स्ट
तो यह चीज़ तो आपको समझ में आ ही रही होगी
यहां पर। यह सारी चीज़ मैंने बताया था। यह
आपका प्र्प्ट है। उसके बाद यह कैरिज
रिटर्न है। उसके बाद फिर से आपका प्र्प्ट
है। फिर यह बटन है। आपका यस या नो है।
वीबी क्वेश्चन मार्क आपका आएगा। अभी भी
डिफॉल्ट बटन सेलेक्ट किया हमने कौन सा
सेकंड वाला उसके बाद कंफर्म डिलीशन ये चीज
सबको समझ में आ रही होगी ये चीज सबको
क्लियर हो रही होगी देन उसके बाद अभी हम
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट अब यहां पर क्या करते हैं
स्टेटमेंट का यूज़ करते हैं इफ स्टेटमेंट
का हम यहां पर यूज़ करते हैं तो चलिए फिर
इफ स्टेटमेंट का यूज़ कर लेते हैं इफ हम
यहां लिखते हैं यूजर चॉइस
यूजर चॉइस
इक्वल हमने लिखा वीबी यस हमें पता था क्या
देन उसके बाद हम लिखते अभी आपको समझने की
जरूरत नहीं कि स्टेटमेंट कैसे लिखी गई आई
विल एक्सप्लेन अभी नहीं बाद में आपको
क्लास के अंदर समझाऊंगा
हैज बीन डिलीटेड
उसके बाद
उसके बाद स्टेटस
ये हो गया। नेक्स्ट
एल्स
मैसेज बॉक्स उसके लिखते हैं।
स्पिन कैंसिल्ड
उसके बाद नाउ
वीबी इनबी
इन देन
स्टेटस
स्टेटस और अभी एंड इसको स्टेटमेंट को एंड
कर देते हैं हम। एंड इफ आई होप समझ में आ
गया होगा। एंड इफ चलो अब इस कोड को हम रन
करके देखते हैं। तो एक बार मैं इसको
अलग-अलग कर देता हूं। अलग-अलग लाइन पे
आपको कोड सबको दिखाई दे रहा है अच्छे से।
कोड सबको अच्छे से दिखाई दे रहा है ना? तो
इसको अभी रन करें। रन होगा बताओ अगर अभी
हम रन करेंगे रन होगा बताओ
अगर अभी हम रन करेंगे तो रन होगा तो चलो
फिर इसको रन कर देते हैं लो डू यू वांट टू
डिलीट दिस फाइल दिस एक्शन कैन नॉट बी अनडन
यस या नो देखो यहां पर देखोगे
कंफर्म डिलीशन यह आपका टाइटल है कंफर्म
डिलीशन यह आपका क्या था टाइटल था
बटन में क्या दिखाई दे रहा है को एक
क्वेश्चन मार्क आइकॉन आइकॉन आया यह बटन की
वजह से यह आपका प्र्प्ट है और यहां पर
देखो डिफॉल्ट सेलेक्ट कौन सा है नो बिकॉज़
इसके लिए हमने क्या लिखा था वीबी डिफॉल्ट
बटन टू अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन और यहां पर यस या
नो तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं यस कर दिया
जैसे यस किया एक और पॉप पॉप अप आया देखो
क्रॉस बटन आया दी फाइल हैज़ बीन डिलीटेड और
ओके
समझ में आया
समझ में आ गया कोड सबको समझ में आ गया
कोड सबको समझ में आ गया
लिखना आ गया बेसिक कोड किसी को कोई डाउट
है इसमें
किसी को इसमें कोई भी डाउट है
किसको डाउट है बताओ नो x आप बोल सर डाउट
है बताओ क्या डाउट है
किसी को कोई डाउट है?
ओके ओके चलो तो आज का सेशन सबको समझ में
आया?
आज का सेशन सबको समझ में आया?
आज का सेशन इतना ही एंड करें।
आज का सेशन इतना ही एंड करें
या
और कुछ पढ़ाऊं? वेरिएबल और पढ़ाऊं आप लोगों
को? वेरिएबल
क्योंकि
मैं सोच रहा हूं कि लंबे सेशन करने में
कहीं ऐसा ना कि आप लोगों को समझ में ना
आए।
चलो फिर मैं बता देता हूं। ओके
नाउ अभी हम आते हैं वेरिएबल्स एंड डेटा
टाइप्स के ऊपर। वेरिएबल्स एंड डेटा टाइप्स
के ऊपर। देखिए जो वेरिएबल्स है वेरिएबल्स
को आप एक बॉक्स की तरह समझ सकते हो। आपके
सामने एक बॉक्स दिखाई दे रहा होगा। आप
वेरिएबल को एक बॉक्स की तरह समझ सकते हो
और बॉक्स के ऊपर जो लेबल लगा होता है जैसे
कि यहां पर एक स्टूडेंट नाम का एक लेबल
लिखा है तो उस लेबल को आप क्या समझ सकते
हो वो लेबल आपका क्या है वेरिएबल नेम
बॉक्स के ऊपर जो लेबल लगा होता है चाहे वो
एड्रेस हो उस बॉक्स का कोई नाम हो तो वो
बॉक्स का जो लेबल है वो क्या कहलाएगा आपका
वेरिएबल नेम और उस बॉक्स के अंदर जो भी
आइटम है जो भी वैल्यू लिखी हुई है उस
बॉक्स के अंदर जो भी आइटम स्टोर है या जो
भी वैल्यू रखी है जगह यहां पर अल तो उसको
हम क्या बोलेंगे? वैल्यू उसको हम क्या
बोलेंगे? वैल्यू। एक बॉक्स है। बॉक्स के
लेबल को हम वेरिएबल नेम बोलेंगे। बॉक्स के
अंदर जो आइटम स्टोर है या उसको हम वैल्यू
बोलेंगे। और उस बॉक्स का जो साइज है उस
बॉक्स का चाहे छोटा बॉक्स हो सकता है,
बड़ा बॉक्स हो सकता है। जो भी उस बॉक्स का
साइज है उसको हम क्या बोलेंगे? डेटा
टाइल्स। समझ में आ गया कि लेबल को वेरिएबल
नेम उसके अंदर वैल्यू को आइटम को वैल्यू
बोलेंगे और बॉक्स का जो साइज है उसको हम
क्या बोलेंगे? डेटा टाइप्स।
बिल्कुल सिंपल शब्दों में सिंपल भाषा में
लेबल वेरिएबल नेम अंदर के आइटम, बॉक्स के
अंदर के आइटम वैल्यू और बॉक्स का साइज
क्या है? आपका डेटा टाइप्स। अब इसका
सिंटेक्स क्या होता है? इसका सिंटेक्स
स्टार्ट होता है डम। अगर हमें कोई भी
वेरिएबल डिक्लेअ करना है बीबीए के अंदर
उसके लिए हम सबसे पहले यूज करते हैं डम
का। डम को बोलते हैं डायमेंशन। ठीक है?
उसके बाद वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद एज
कीवर्ड उसके बाद वेरिएबल का टाइप। यहां पर
आप वेरिएबल का नाम लिखते हैं और यहां पर
आप उसका डेटा टाइप लिखते हैं कि जो बॉक्स
है उस बॉक्स का साइज क्या होगा? बॉक्स के
अंदर आप जो वैल्यू स्टोर कर रहे हो उसका
साइज क्या होगा? उसको हम बोलते हैं डेटा
टाइप। तो आप क्या करते हो? पहले डम कीवर्ड
का यूज़ करते हो। उसके वेरिएबल का नाम उसके
बाद वेरिएबल का टाइप वहां पर मेंशन करते
हैं। अब जो वेरिएबल नेम है इसको लिखने के
भी रूल्स होते हैं। तो वह रूल्स मैं आपके
सामने बता देता हूं। तो सबसे पहला रूल
होता है दी फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर मस्ट ऑलवेज बी
ए लेटर मतलब अल्फाबेट। यू कैन नॉट स्टार्ट
ए वेरिएबल नेम विद ए नंबर। के इसका मतलब
क्या है कि जो जो वेरिएबल स्टार्ट करोगे
उसका जो फर्स्ट लेटर है हमेशा वो आपका
अल्फाबेट होना चाहिए। वह कभी भी इस तरीके
से फर्स्ट यूजर 99 बॉटल्स इस तरीके से
इनवैलिड है। कभी भी स्टार्ट नहीं हो सकता।
यह एक वैलिड गैस है। दूसरा रूल क्या बोलता
है? आप वेरिएबल में स्पेसज फुल स्टॉप
स्पेशल कररेक्टर्स जैसे कि एस्केलेशन
मार्क्स @#ग डॉलर आप नहीं यूज कर सकते। आप
सिर्फ अंडरस्कोर यूज कर सकते हैं। अगर
चाहो तो यूज़ करना। मतलब यूजर अंडरस्कोर एज
या फर्स्ट अंडरस्कोर नेम यह आपका एक वैलिड
है। बट अगर इनवैलिड केस की देखें यूजर
स्पेस नेम यूजर डॉट नेम यह आपका एक
इनवैलिड केस है। अंडरस्टुड रूल नंबर दो।
रूल नंबर थ्री क्या है? रूल नंबर थ्री में
आप क्या है कि जो आपका वेरिएबल नेम
वेरिएबल नेम्स होते हैं वो केस इनसेंसिटिव
होते हैं। केस सेंसिटिव क्या होता है? कि
अगर आपने यूजरनेम ऐसे लिखा है एक इस तरीके
से एक इस तरीके से तो उसका मतलब क्या है
कि यह दोनों वेरिएबल नेम अलग-अलग होते
हैं। लेकिन वीबीए के केस में यह क्या है?
केस इनसेंसिटिव। मतलब अगर आपने यूजरनेम
ऐसे लिखा हो, चाहे यूजरनेम ऐसे लिखा हो,
चाहे यूजरनेम ऐसे लिखा हो, तो यह एक ही
माना जाएगा क्योंकि यह केस इनसेंसिटिव है।
अगर आप यूजरनेम ऐसे लिखो, ऐसे लिखो या ऐसे
लिखो। अगर आप तीन बार ऐसे लिखोगे तो आपको
एरर देखने को मिलेगा। बिकॉज़ ये क्योंकि एक
ही है। यहां पर केस इनसेंसिटिव है। केस
सेंसिटिव होता तो ये तीनों अलग-अलग
वेरिएबल नेम होते। लेकिन केस इनसेंसिटिव
केस में ये तीनों वेरिएबल नेम एक ही है।
उसके बाद यू कैन नॉट यूज़ वीबी ए रिजर्व
कीवर्ड्स। मतलब क्या है कि आप जो रिजर्व
कीवर्ड्स होते हैं जैसे सब हो गया, फंक्शन
कीवर्ड हो गया, डिम कीवर्ड हो गया, एंड
कीवर्ड हो गया। इनको आप क्या नहीं कर
सकते? वेरिएबल के नेम में यूज़ नहीं कर
सकते। आप इसको वेरिएबल के नेम में यूज़
नहीं कर सकते।
अभी जो डेटा टाइप्स होते हैं, दो टाइप्स
के डेटा टाइप्स होते हैं वेरिएबल के अंदर।
सबसे पहला होता है आपका न्यूमैरिक डेटा
टाइप। दूसरा होता है आपका नॉन न्यूममेरिक
डेटा टाइप्स। न्यूममेरिक डेटा टाइप्स में
आप आते हैं आपके बाइट, इंटीजर, लॉन्ग,
सिंगल, डबल, डेसिमल। यह आते हैं आपके
न्यूमेरिक डाटा टाइप में। अगर आपको कोई
काउंट काउंटिंग का काम करना है या कोई
कैलकुलेशन करनी है, कोई मैथमेटिकल
कैलकुलेशन जैसे टास्क परफॉर्म करने है तो
आप न्यूममेरिक डेटा टाइप का यूज़ करते हो।
अदरवाइज आप नॉन न्यूममेरिक डेटा टाइप का
यूज़ करते हो। अगर आपको कोई टेक्स्ट
टेक्स्ट स्ट्रिंग्स के साथ डील करनी है,
डेट के साथ डील करनी है, ट्रू या फॉल्स
वैल्यू के साथ डील करनी है, ऑब्जेक्ट के
साथ डील करनी है, तो उस केस में आप यूज़
करते हो स्ट्रिंग, डेट, बुलियन, ऑब्जेक्ट,
वेरिएंट। इस टाइप के डेट टाइप का यूज़ करते
हैं। अभी एक केस और होता है कि अगर आप
क्या करते हो कि आप कोई भी डेटा टाइप
स्पेसिफाई नहीं करते। किसके अंदर? वेरिएबल
नेम के अंदर। तो उस केस में क्या होता है?
उसका जो डेटा टाइप होता है वह ऑटोमेटिकली
वेरिएंट डेटा टाइप होता है। अब वेरिएंट
डेटा टाइप क्या होता है? वेरिएंट डेटा
टाइप किसी भी टाइप का डेटा स्टोर कर सकता
है। स्ट्रिंग भी स्टोर कर सकता है, इंटीजर
भी स्टोर कर सकता है। किसी भी टाइप का वो
डेटा स्टोर कर सकता है। उसमें कोई पाबंदी
नहीं है। अगर आप डिफॉल्ट छोड़ देते हो अगर
आप डेटा टाइप नहीं लिखते तो तब भी आप उसके
अंदर इंटीजर भी स्टोर कर सकते हो। आप
ऑब्जेक्ट भी स्टोर कर सकते कुछ भी स्टोर
कर सकते हो। बट क्या है कि उसका साइज बहुत
बड़ा होता है। क्योंकि आपको नहीं पता होगा
कि जब भी आप कोई भी वेरिएबल डिफाइन करते
हो तो वो क्या करता है? उस सिस्टम में एक
मेमोरी असाइन करता है उस पर्टिकुलर वैल्यू
के लिए। तो अगर आप वेरिएंट डेटा टाइप रखते
हो तो उसमें क्या होगा? उसकी जो मेमोरी
उसकी जो वैल्यू है उसका साइज बड़ा होगा।
जिसकी वजह से क्या होगा? थोड़ी सी आपके जो
कोड है अगर छोटा कोड है तो फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा। अगर कोड ज्यादा बड़ा है तो क्या
होगा? उसमें लेग लैग्स करेगा। क्या उसका
वो स्लो करेगा। उसका एग्जीक्यूशन थोड़ा
स्लो होगा बाकी कोड से। यह था आपका
वेरिएबल्स। आपको समझ में आ गया वेरिएबल्स?
तो हम आपको अभी प्रैक्टिकली लेके चलता हूं
वेरिएबल्स के किस के ऊपर। तो प्रैक्टिकली
चलते हैं कि वेरिएबल नेम आप लिखते कैसे
हो? तो जैसे कि मैंने क्या लिखा? आपको पता
तो है। अभी आप वेरिएबल वैसे लिखा तो ये
रहा देखो
डम वेरिएबल नेम उसके बाद एज कीवर्ड डेटा
टाइप्स। ठीक है?
ओके? देखो डम वेरिएबल नेम एज डेटा टाइप्स
और भी लिख सकते हो। जैसे कि अभी मैं इसको
क्लियर कर देता हूं पूरा तरीके से और
वेरिएबल का केस कर देता हूं। जैसे मैंने
क्या लिखा? पहले वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन वाला
सिखाता हूं कि सबसे पहले मैं आपको कमेंट
करके दिखाता हूं।
वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन। वेरिएबल डिक्लेरेशन
आप कैसे लिख सकते हो? डम। उसके बाद आपने
लिखा
स्टूडेंट नेम
एज स्ट्रिंग
स्टूडेंट नेम स्ट्रिंग उसके बाद डम आपने
लिखा
स्टूडेंट एज
एज इंटजर बाइट
बाइट उसके बाद डम इस तरीके से आप क्या कर
सकते हो वेरिएबल नेम लिख सकते हो
टोटल मार्क्स
इंटजर देन उसके बाद आपने लिखा नेम उसके
बाद इज पास्ड
एज
ओके इज पास स्पेस दे दिया तो आपका वेरिएबल
नेम गलत हो गया इज पास्ड जैसे मैंने उसको
रूल बताया था आपको उसके बाद बुलियन
देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं इसके अंदर
वैल्यू असाइन करते हैं ठीक है उसके इसके
अंदर वैल्यू असाइन करते हैं। तो देखो
असाइनिंग
असाइनिंग वैल्यूज़ आप वैल्यू ऐसे भी लिख
सकते हो और एक साथ भी वैल्यू असाइन कर
सकते हो। उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता। बट
मैं आपको सही प्रोसीजर दिखा रहा हूं। एक
स्टूडेंट नेम यहां पर आप वैल्यू स्टोर
करोगे। मैंने लिखा सचिन।
देन उसके बाद मैं लिखता हूं
स्टूडेंट एज उसके बाद हमने क्या लिखा 21
उसके बाद
टोटल मार्क्स
पास
ट्रू
हो गया देन अब हम लिखते हैं आउटपुट कैसे
लिखना है
आउटपुट। चलो फिर कर देते हैं। आउटपुट कैसे
लिखेंगे? आउटपुट के लिए मैसेज बॉक्स का
यूज करेंगे। चलो बैक मैसेज बॉक्स का यूज़
कर लेते हैं। हम लिख लेते हैं अभी
स्टूडेंट नेम।
उसके बाद एंड एम परसेंट का यूज़ एंड के यूज़
करेंगे। स्टूडेंट नेम
उसके बाद एंड और एक और आप यूज कर सकते हो
वी बी
सी आर
एल एफ यह भी आप यूज़ कर सकते हो इसके अंदर
देन हम यूज़ करेंगे
एज
स्टूडेंट एज
ओके ओके सीबी नहीं ये बीबी था यार बीबी
बी बी सी आर ये वाला
देन उसके बाद एंड कीवर्ड फिर से हम यूज़
करेंगे अभी मार्क्स
समझ में आ रहा है आप लोगों को बता दीजिए
मुझे अगर नहीं समझ में आ रहा तो वह भी बता
दीजिए
टोटल मार्क्स एफेशेंट
देन फिर
उसके बाद
फिर एफेशेंट
देन उसके बाद हम फिर से लिखते हैं पास्ट
स्टूडेंट
पास्ट स्टेटस
इज पास
उसके बाद वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन
वीबी इंफॉर्मेशन उसके बाद
स्टूडेंट
रिकॉर्ड
स्टूडेंट रिकॉर्ड
सब कुछ समझ में आ रहा है?
ओके।
बेबी यहां पे देखो अभी यहां पर कहीं ना
कहीं हमने कुछ गड़बड़ की है इस कोड में।
हम देखते हैं फटाफट कहां पर गड़बड़ की है।
यह रहा
इज पास। के बाद हमने क्या करना था? यह
गड़बड़ की थी। और आपको समझ में आ गया?
यह रहा। अब इसको रन करें।
इसको रन करें।
चलो इस कोड को क्या करते हैं हम? रन। और
ये रहा स्टूडेंट रिकॉर्ड। स्टूडेंट नेम
सचिन एस 21452
ओके अंडरस्टुड?
सबको समझ में आ गया?
बताओ। यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया?
यहां तक क्लियर है
बताओ।
तो यह था आपका आज का सेशन। आई होप सबको
सेशन में मजा आया होगा। मुझे नहीं पता आप
लोगों को मजा आया नहीं आया। तो मैं उम्मीद
कर सकता हूं शायद आप लोगों को मजा आया
होगा क्योंकि मैं सिर्फ कोशिश कर सकता हूं
लेकिन मुझे आप लोगों को इंटरेस्ट देख के
लगता नहीं कि आप लोग सच में कुछ करने वाले
हो क्योंकि
कुछ नहीं है छोड़ो यार
तो यहां पर सबने ज्वाइन कर लिया ग्रुप
ज्वाइन कर लिया क्लास नोट्स वाला
कितने लोगों ने यहां पर ज्वाइन नहीं किया
है
देखो आप लोगों को अगर पीपीटी चाहिए नोट्स
चाहिए तो इसलिए मैंने आप लोगों के लिए वह
स्पेशली बनाया है प्रीवियस क्लास के धीरे
क्योंकि जैसे-जैसे स्टूडेंट उसको ज्वाइन
कर लेंगे मुझे लगा कि मैक्सिमम स्टूडेंट्स
उसमें आ गए देन मैं आपको उसमें क्या
करूंगा
मैं उसमें नोट्स शेयर कर दूंगा अगर आप
लोगों को नोट्स चाहिए तो वहीं पर जाकर
मिलेंगे
अगला जो सेशन होगा उसमें और भी ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा क्योंकि अब अगले सेशन
में हम मैक्सिमम क्या करने वाले हैं?
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट स्टार्ट करेंगे। मैं
ठीक है? अगले सेशन में क्या करने वाले हैं
हम? नेक्स्ट में डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट के साथ
कैसे इंटरेक्ट करते हैं? पेलोड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जो पेलोड डेवलपमेंट की तैयारी स्टार्ट
करेंगे अगले सेशन में। ठीक है? कि पेलोड
पेलोड डेवलपमेंट ही चल रहा है बेसिकली
क्योंकि आपके फंडामेंटल मैंने क्लियर कर
दिए तो पेलोड कैसे लिख सकते हो आप इसमें
वीबीएमए अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन आप लोगों को
लगता है कि ये नॉर्मल चीज है पर नॉर्मल
चीज नहीं है अभी तक तो दो क्लास में बेसिक
खत्म हो जाता मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
मैं एक एक कॉमन इमेज लेता और उसमें आपको
पढ़ा देता बट मैंने आपके लिए स्लाइड रेडी
की है। एक-एक चीज बिल्कुल बारीकी से
डिफाइन की है ताकि आप लोगों को डाउट ना
रहे। प्रैक्टिकल प्लस थ्योरी आई होप कि
सबको अच्छा लगा होगा।
चलिए फिर से सेशन से रिलेटेड आपके किसी
कोई भी डाउट है? सेशन से रिलेटेड आपका कोई
भी डाउट है।
किसी का कोई भी डाउट हो सेशन से रिलेटेड
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कोई डाउट नहीं है।
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट हो
वह पूछ लो।
कोई डाउट नहीं है।
डेली क्लास
मैं तो कर लूंगा बट आप लोग आई होप कि
डिर्व नहीं करते मेरी तरफ से। बिकॉज़ 10
स्टूडेंट को ले मैं डेली क्लास में मैं
अपना टाइम वेस्ट कैसे वेस्ट कर दूंगा यार।
आप सोचिए मेरा टाइम बहुत ज्यादा वैल्यू आप
लोगों से।
क्योंकि
मैं अगर पूरा टाइम आपको देने के लिए रेडी
हूं। बट आप लोग रेडी नहीं हो ना?
अगर मेरी क्लास में आप 100 लाइव आते उसके
बाद
पूरी
बहुत सारे लोग देखते हैं तो मैं मानता बट
आप लोग आते ही 10 12 हो
तो इसलिए फ्रीक्वेंसी स्लो है। फिर भी मैं
अभी देखो कल नहीं ले सकता। मैं भी ट्राई
करूंगा कि
परसों वेडनेसडे को आपकी क्लास लूं।
फ्रीक्वेंसी मैं बढ़ाने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं। बट आप लोग चाहते नहीं फ्रीक्वेंसी
बढ़वाना। तो जब मैं सोचता हूं जबजब मैं
सोचता हूं क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ाने की
तबतब आप लोग क्या करते हो ना? यही करते
हो।
देखो मैं तुम्हारी बात समझता हूं।
कार्तिकीय जो लोग डिर्व करते हैं भाई मुझे
इतना पता है कि सिर्फ दो लोग ही डिर्व
नहीं करते।
इस देश में लाखों करोड़ों लोग हैं जो
डिर्व करते हैं।
यह उन सबके लिए है। लेकिन दो लोग तक ही
पहुंच रही है। या तो फिर मुझ में कमी है
या फिर क्लास देखने वालों में कमी है।
या लोगों को विश्वास नहीं है।
लोगों को पैसे देकर पढ़ने पर विश्वास है
या फिर यहां पर विश्वास नहीं है कि कंटेंट
सिर्फ टाइम पास के लिए क्योंकि मुझे पता
है बहुत सारी मार्केटिंग ऐसी भी चल रही
है। बहुत सारी मार्केटिंग मेरे भी सामने
आती हैं कि
अ कि लोग क्या करते हैं कि ट्यूटोरियल ये
यही मन में है कि ट्यूटोरियल देख के आप
कोई भी एग्जाम क्रैक नहीं कर सकते। आप कुछ
भी नहीं बन सकते। बट एक चीज है बात सही है
लेकिन वो ट्यूटोरियल देख के आप कोई भी
एग्जाम या कोई भी तैयारी नहीं कर सकते जो
आपके एक प्रिपयर्ड वे में नहीं हो जो आपको
एक सिलेबस के रूप में ना हो डीएचई डे वन
से क्लास वन से जब भी इसकी जो भी क्लास
हुई है अकॉर्डिंग टू सिलेबस हुई है आउट ऑफ
सिलेबस से ज्यादा ही हुआ है लेकिन कुछ भी
ऐसा नहीं हुआ कि आपको फेक पढ़ाया गया हो
पेड कोर्स की तरह ही इसको पढ़ाया गया है
और पढ़ाया जा रहा है क्योंकि यही चीज है
जो आप पेड कोर्सेज में पढ़ते हैं।
ठीक है? आप पेड कोर्सेज में यही चीजें
पढ़ते हैं। बट
प्रॉब्लम यह है कि क्योंकि मैं मानता हूं
यार क्योंकि इतनी सारी चीजें चल रही है
YouTube पे। बहुत सारी ऐसी ट्यूटोरियल्स
हैं जहां पर थंबनेल्स कुछ है। थंबनेल्स के
अंदर जस्ट वही चार कमांड्स होती हैं।
पांचवी कमांड में बोला हमने करके दिखा
दिया। बट नोबडी टेल यू कि आपने इसमें
इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग की है। एक्सटर्नल
पेंट टेस्टिंग की है या आपने जो चीज
परफॉर्म करके दिखाई है वह किस पर डिपेंड
करती है? मेरी क्लासेस में साफ-साफ बोला
है कि अगर आपको यह पर्टिकुलर आप एक्सप्लइट
ट्राई कर रहे हो या पर्टिकुलर क्लास ट्राई
कर रहे हो या पर्टिकुलर जो प्रैक्टिकल आप
परफॉर्म करोगे उसके लिए आप खासकर मैंने जब
इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग पढ़ाई थी कि आप उस
नेटवर्क के अंदर होने चाहिए। बाहर से नहीं
कर सकते आप इस पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लोइट को
ट्राई। मैंने साफ-साफ बोला। मैंने यह नहीं
बोला कि आपको कि नहीं आप कर सकते हो। मैं
बोल सकता था बट नो
साफसाफ बताता हूं। एक्स्ट्रा पटेस्टिंग
सिखा रहा था तो इतना ही कर सकते हो। यहां
जाकर आप पटकोगे उसके लिए आपको और कुछ करना
पड़ेगा। साफ-साफ बोलो।
वही चीज है। मैं वही पढ़ाता हूं आपको।
मुझे पता है कि ओनली अगर डीएचई काफी लॉन्ग
टाइम से चल रही है और बहुत सारी क्लासेस
इसकी आनी है और मुझे पता है कि ओनली
सैटरडे संडे को क्लास लेके आप लोग भी सोच
रहे हो कि सर मैं इससे बेटर आपको पैसे दूं
और आपके डेली क्लासेस लूं तो वो बेटर
रहेगा। बट भाई बहुत लोग उसको एफर्ट नहीं
कर सकते। इसलिए इसको चलाया हुआ है। अगर
आपने 77 वीडियो है आज 77 तक की आपने अगर
वीडियो को एक-एक बार भी देख लिया उसके
नोट्स आपने पढ़ लिए उसकी अगर आपने
प्रैक्टिस नहीं भी कर पाए लेकिन आपको
ध्यान से समझ लिया तो एक चीज खुद ये बताइए
कि क्या इसमें वो चीज नहीं है जो एक पेड
कोर्स में हो
और मे बी दिस संडे समथिंग इज कमिंग न्यू
जो ऐसी चीजें अगर आपको मोटिवेशन नहीं मिल
रहा आपको ऐसी चीजें जो आपको अ
पता ही नहीं ऐसी सच्चाई जो आपको जाननी है
साइबर वर्ल्ड की वो भी हम कुछ लेके आएंगे।
तो चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं और आपका
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे। तो बाय-ब एवरीवन।
अगर आपके कोई भी डाउट्स हैं तो मैं एक काम
करूंगा। पहले आप लोग Twitter पर नहीं सॉरी
Twitter नहीं अपने जो हमारा Telegram है
Telegram के जो क्लास नोट्स वाले ग्रुप
में आ जाइए। वहां से फिर आपका एक डिस्कशन
ग्रुप भी बना दिया जाएगा जिससे हम वहां पर
अपने डाउट्स ओनली डिस्कस कर पाए चीजें।
उसका भी कुछ सलूशन निकाल लूंगा मैं। तो
इसलिए आपके लिए बनाया मैंने। इट इज ए
दोबारा बता देता हूं। प्लीज यह जो वीडियो
है आज की इसके लिंक में है अवेलेबल आपके
क्लास नोट के नाम से तो आप उसको जाइए वहां
पर क्लिक कीजिए उसको ज्वाइन कर लीजिए
उसमें आपको सारे नोट्स धीरे-धीरे शेयर कर
दिए जाएंगे
हां यस तो अब आपको अगर यहां भी चाहिए तो
मैं यहां पर भी शेयर कर सकता हूं गिव मी 1
मिनट्स
चलो मैं यहां पर आपको लिंक शेयर ही कर
देता हूं इट्स ओके अगर किसी ने नहीं किया
है तो आप लोग अपने दोस्तों के साथ भी कर
सकते हो शेयर
एकडमी नोट्स आपको चाहिए पढ़ने के लिए
पढ़ाने के लिए तो भी आप कर सकते हो और यह
रहा
लो
मेबी लिंक इसमें वो नहीं करेगा। यह
कंट्रोल जेड
वेट वेट
वेट इसमें लिंक थोड़ा अच्छे से पेस्ट नहीं
होगा। इट्स ओके फाइन
लो।
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। बाय-ब
एवरीवन एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन। सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन।